so it has just been confirmed via social
media their website in which the royal
family have said the queen died
peacefully at Balmoral this afternoon
they add the king and the queen consort
will remain at Balmoral this evening and
will return to London tomorrow
this will clearly come as devastating
news
for the royal family and millions of
people across the United Kingdom and
around the world
Queen Elizabeth II was a much loved and
respected Monarch and a truly unique
figure on the world stage a head of
state without equal admired not just
here in the United Kingdom but across
the globe by members of the public
politicians and religious leaders
many of us will simply not remember a
time when she wasn't our head of state
and she was a constant figure in every
aspect of National Life
from becoming Queen when she was only 25
she then went on to become Britain's
longest reigning monarch and displayed
this unwavering commitment to her
country and her Commonwealth throughout
what was a truly record-breaking reign
now her dedication to that
constitutional role was never questioned
but for her family were just as
important to her as a devoted wife
mother grandmother and great-grandmother
and their admiration for her was always
so clearly seen when she was surrounded
by her family when we saw those moments
of great national celebration and
reflection
it's worth saying that for many her
reign will forever be defined by what
was a selfless sense of Duty
but it wasn't about her own personal
power privilege or entitlement this was
a role that she felt that she was she
was born to fulfill her quiet and
restrained demeanor was always guiding
her family and the United Kingdom
through what was a extraordinary period
of social and political change but
throughout all of that she was always
conscious of keeping the monarchy
relevant and while respecting as well
and upholding important Traditions she
often showed this adaptability that many
will now credit with securing the future
of the institution
it is worth saying that her old age
really should not detract from the
enormity of this news and the huge
constitutional change that her death now
brings
for nearly 70 years
she was this symbol of stability and
continuity and for so many always a
figure of national pride who really
embodied those values of public service
and Duty well into her 90s and as we saw
this week until the very end
now the United Kingdom and The
Commonwealth Realms will witness a
period of reflection and constitutional
change
which many of us will never have
experienced in our lifetime
as we now mourn the death of Queen
Elizabeth II and witness the succession
of her son as the new king
and Rhiannon we last Saw Her Majesty the
queen in public of course just
two days ago when she asked this Truss
to form her government to become her
15th prime minister
it was remarkable we saw
until the end really that determination
to
simply carry on with her constitutional
duties and and no she wasn't able to
travel down to London
to appoint her 15th prime minister as
she had done with all of her other Prime
Ministers throughout her 70-year Reign
but she wanted to make sure that she was
seen
by members of the public to be
continuing on with those constitutional
duties
and we saw that in practice there the
queen reaching her hand out to appoint
Liz truss
as her 15th prime minister
I think that is why this announcement of
her death will be such a shock to so
many
but over the last 12 months there is no
doubt that we have seen a gradual
slowing down a gradual change in the
duties that she felt that she was able
to carry out I think it was important
for her to be seen to to carry out that
Handover of power between prime
ministers because we hadn't seen her in
public for quite a long time she'd
obviously traveled up to Scotland where
she was enjoying her summer break
previously the last time that we saw her
was when she visited a hospice
accompanied by Princess Anne and that
was in July
and we saw with her she was there once
again carrying that stick because we
know over the last 12 months
she was having difficulty with her
Mobility the palace often describing it
as episodic Mobility problems which did
mean that sometimes she she wasn't able
to attend certain engagements but I
think what was striking there is to see
Princess Anne alongside her and that has
been a theme that we have witnessed
right throughout the last 12 months is
the family being there to make sure that
when she felt she was able to go out and
meet the public as she has done as she
did right throughout her 70-year reign
they could support her and they could be
there in any way that they needed her
and of course we had the Platinum
Jubilee
just months ago the first British
monarch to ever Mark that remarkable
milestone
and we were wondering around that
weekend how much we would be able to see
her because of the difficulties that
she'd been having
but I think you could see that she
wanted to make that effort she knew the
crowds once again had come out to mark
that Milestone moment with her
but also that Platinum Jubilee was so
Central in the queen showing her wishes
for the future
there alongside her
were those sensual key members of the
royal family that she knew she was
passing on those responsibilities to
the Prince of Wales
The Duchess of Cornwall the Prince of
Wales it has to be said now our new king
and to the other side of her the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge and their three
children
in those images there was a very clear
message from the queen a sense of future
proofing the monarchy as she did right
throughout those seven decades saying
this is my family who I love very much
who I trust who have shown already how
committed they are to you the public how
committed they are to the country and
the Commonwealth and you should trust
them when it comes to me stepping back
from my responsibilities today of course
though the family will be around her
they have all traveled to Balmoral to be
alongside her as now we Mark her death